professor kazanova it is a great
pleasure for us to have you here at Yale
and to participate in this interview
with us many of us here around the globe
have appreciated very much both the
extent of your work and the depth of
your understanding of social phenomena
in particular phenomenon of religion for
many today it still seems that
expectation that in the course of
modernity religions will decline both in
terms of their social influence and in
terms of individual practice that's
almost like a given expectation you have
been one of the early detractors of the
so-called secularization thesis why well
I guess the background is I come from
Europe and in Europe I took these theses
for granted and I came to the United
States and it took me very long time to
understand why a modern secular society
like the darkness this could be
shortened leaders and of course you can
say well this is the exception to the
rule but the rule still holds then you
realize this is not a very good answer
and then the more you look around the
world you realize that you have a lot of
decent countries which are modernizing
but they said mean that they are
religious not a decline on the contrary
religion becomes for the first time a
key contested a centrally contested
issue in the process of political
democratization mobilization so I think
that it forced me to rethink the
paradigms of secularization which are at
the center of my own discipline
sociology and you don't you don't take
these what some described as resurgence
of religion as we look around the globe
you don't take those to be something
like a last gasp of religion before the
onslaught of modernity which will from
within kind of undermined and render
redundant religious convictions and ruin
roll a lot of role of religion in
society why well because we're still
caught in the old model there was
religion in the past before modernity
then come secular mother
and makes a religion precisely
irrelevant in this we have this last gap
of anti modern anti secular reaction
which we call fundamentalism I think
that only we propose that modernization
means secularization in the sense in
which religion the old religion
disappear but modernization itself
radically transforms all religions and
there is a sense in which what we call
Western secularization is so
intrinsically related to preserve the
transformation of Western Christianity
this preserve so interrelated at the
very clear separation of the boundaries
of the sacred and the religious is very
problematic again here I think the
United States is very clear since the
French model which is the kind of Lake
model and the clinical model is -
precisely clearly differentiated spheres
keep the boundaries very clear and make
religion a very smaller and marginalize
the Protestant to a certain extent the
American model is actually you dissolve
the boundaries and religion is supposed
to become secular and the secular become
religious and you never know where
religion begins and the secular ends if
you take this model then it means that
modernization means not so much you know
this secularization - religion that
religion disappears but a radical
transformation of the relation between
this thing that we call religion and the
secular which of course is a very
Christian way of looking at this matters
and for other religions these boundaries
did not exist so the question is how are
the boundaries remade re-define and so
it's a question more of analyzing
transformations going on at all levels
rather than thinking of these separate
processes if we step back for a moment
from a kind of Western setting and the
conjunction certain conjunction between
Western religious as well as political
economic traditions and what happened
described as secularization processes
one might speak as some people have done
and I know that you have as well done
all kind of multiple modernities on
the one of which might be one version of
maternity might be a secularizing one
would you would you care to explore but
explain a concept of multiple eternities
this is the most interesting on a much
interesting kind of intellectual
analytical framework being developed now
linked in history social science
philosophy the category comes is linked
to the axial revolutions theses Jasper's
was the one that developed the notion
that there was a fundamental egg axial
revolution that gave birth to the great
civilizations we know them in radical is
understood as the emergence of a
principle of transcendence a separation
between reality as we know it's
basically political power and the
possibility of a transcendent principle
with which to judge evaluate this one
and of course this is very different in
the Platonic notion of the ideas and the
cave the allegory of the cave or in the
Confucian Ocean of a towel versus the
kind of monotheistic notion of a
transcendent God but the notion is that
somehow in the axial revolutions you
have in a structure of a dualism of the
mundane order in a transcendent order
which seems to evil that is used to
evaluate now if we understand secular
modernity is the particular process of
transformation of a version of an actual
civilization and then which is which is
precisely as this characterization of
having defined reality in terms of the
religion and the secular so the secular
was a religious category within
Christian theology but then the secular
becomes the dominating category that
then shapes religion but is a process
which is an internal transformation of a
particular Christian Western
civilization but then becomes globalized
through colonial globalization so the
question is how does this model of
relate in the spheres the transcendence
moondyne order which extend the modern
secular modernity means to put it in in
some stylish terms the emergence of an
imminent frame without transcendence and
which accent this is globalized and then
enters encounters already pre-existing
ways
of organizing these relations in which
kind of dynamics of transformation then
occur so the the multiple modalities I
think it cannot be it should not be
understood as the West being secular and
the rest not being secular but the
Western secular modernity itself is a
form of a post-christian and very much
implicated with particular Christian
transformations so the other modalities
will be post Hindu post confusion post
Muslim in the sense that both it will be
continuities and discontinuities but it
will be it will be shaped by our dynamic
which is global which emerges out of the
West because it originates here but then
the process of transformation is one of
transformation of traditions not of a
modernity against tradition this is the
way in which we understood the relation
there was tradition and modernity
replaces tradition yes there is a
tradition of modernity but this relation
of modernity is very much shaped by the
prey model tradition and this is
happening everywhere right Charles
Taylor has spoken in in one of his
articles about our kind of our cultural
elements of modernization and then what
he described I think somewhat plausibly
but idiosyncratically may be cultural
elements of globalization where notions
of of Muro of modernity where notions of
the self of society of nature and of the
good are on the cultural side and then
there are those are cultural processes
and these two combine together somehow
give a particular flavor of specific
modernity
how would you parse out what's common in
multiple modernity's and what's
specifically different well I think that
if I may the way understand Charles
Taylor's idea here is very much linked
to the notion of the actual revolution
is the beginning of a process of this
embedding of the self from a structure
in which cosmos society cosmos been in
nature society in the self are or in the
gods the natural the supernal
all of them are in one in man in frame
was the sacred and the profane we're all
in
and before the merchants of axial
transcendence and part of these arcs of
self-transcendence is the beginning of
this embedding of the self from society
the emergence of the self and so the
emergence of the self it's a key
component this process but these then
become radicalized through the
transformation of precisely mother
individual self they would equals the
batter self that he has analysed the
world so the question is then you have
an imminent frame of let's say a cosmos
that we understand in terms of the the
universe scientific conception of the
universe a conception of society which
is based on this horizontal systems of
relations of people coming together for
mutual benefit States markets public
spheres and the notion of buff ourselves
but then of course you have still the
existence of these traditions axial
impression of how these things are
interrelated so the interesting question
is how these eminent frame itself then
becomes the frame within which
individuals have to transform their
identities so for me the interesting
question is why the same imminent frame
in Europe in the United States creates
very different possibilities for either
face t'k belief or non theistic belief
let's say as he put it in Europe to
believe in God today becomes almost a
very difficult option while unbelief
becomes the takin programmed the easy
solution but in the United States is not
the case the theistic option is that the
normal option and the other becomes a
minority an option so the question of
how within the same imminent frame is
still very different possibilities of
relationship of the South to something
else which is transcendence or not and I
think that here the question is what is
the way in which this imminent frame
becomes globalized because there is a
globalization of of these structures
science and technologies being
globalized
the same kind of model for a market
economy market economy the state is a
system and also a certain a public a
sphere through media and so on but then
precisely how this is integrated in
conceptions of the good the issue of
even the public sphere houses the public
sphere related
different forms of democracy into
different conceptions of the south to
discursive traditions of what is the
common good justice how individuals are
laid to others the kind of interactive
kind of connectivity link to precisely
theories of the public good of justice
of how to be a good self is that what
you watch you mentioned once when you
made a distinction between a kind of
structural process socio economic
processes versus something like broadly
construed I take it regimes of of
knowledge and of reading the reality or
knowledge I use it because I'm more and
more convinced you know the old theory
of secularization was a kind of a
metaphysical theory somehow
modernization Zaha produces
secularization but it's not clear how
this happened
in a civil vs automatic no couriers no
actors no agents and no structures of
how this is reproduced and I'm more and
more convinced the very same knowledge
regime of secularism that saves our
imaginary United in Europe look you ask
we know that people lie to the pollsters
in America you ask them how religious
they are and they lie and they say there
are more religious they truly are they
say they pray more frequently that they
do that they go to church more
frequently than they do so there is a
sense in which they believe that they
ought to be religious but they know they
are not as the leaders as they ought to
be so the question the expectations' is
the Americans good modern America's not
in Americans want to be modern but they
want to be modern what to be religious
and so they feel their art is religious
they ought to be so they lie in Europe
ease our way around they want to be
modern but we mother means to be secular
so if you ask them how religious they
are the normal response is god forbid of
course I'm not religious I'm a secular
mother enlighten European what do you
think and I noticed in Spain than the
new surveys that people when you ask
them how frequently they go to church
how much they believe in God you have
different numbers much lower in America
but when you ask them how religious they
are they all think no I'm not religious
at all so even people that takes it go
to church frequently and pray frequently
they find them so they are no not
religious because somehow is not a good
thing so these very different definition
of the situation each which I would call
the knowledge regime of secularism in
Europe in which secularism becomes our
self-fulfilling prophesy in Europe once
you define modernity as secular and
people want to be modern then they want
to be secular so there is a certain of
conversion to secularity and the part of
Europeans because they want to be modern
so in a sense what I'm what I'm hearing
from you for a while in various
disciplines religions seem to be
something to be explained and secularism
seemed like a rational default position
what you're suggesting I'm hearing you
rightly is that secularism itself also
may need to be explained in in various
ways loose talal asad the first world
who heard about 8 9 years ago made the
proposal we need an anthropology of
secularism rather than anthropology of
religion today this is what we need to
do and that's true
I'm a comparing I mean he's more a kind
of a general logic model of social
science my model is comparative
historical so much for me the
interesting question is ok we talk of
secularism in the singular but look
French secularism is very different from
other European cigarettes and beer even
from the American very free from the
turkeys from Indian from Chinese
southern talk of secularism
let's do serious comparative historical
analysis of secularism in terms of
conceptions of a secular state visible
religion and society because even in
terms of the secular state a secular
state and the secularism has two
components one the part of separation of
the state from religion and how much
establishment this is talisman how much
how which kind of wall of separation
exists there but the other is the kind
of model of exercise of religion how
free is the exercise of religion how
real is the how much is it managed
managed by the state how much is the
self developed civil society model so
here it's not only that you have
different models of separation of church
and state
you have very different models of state
management of
in society so we need to precisely study
how those things work out as part of
modernization precisely in different
places one of the things that you've
drawn attention to was it seems when you
put it very natural one and namely if it
is true that religions continue to be
vibrant in the world today then maybe we
need to shift the attention of what we
study from kind of possible decline of
religions and who I decline why not to
the kind of transformations of religions
and religions that are undergoing major
transformations in the globalization
situation can you comment about types of
transformations that are happening I
know it's a huge question but I think
it's a very important one of course the
first model of transformation was of
course Protestant Christianity
Protestant Christianity disrespects the
first modern religion and so precisely
because Protestant Christianity was the
model of how a religion is transformed
in modernity it became also the
parameter of how other religions were
going to be transformed and then when it
becomes the model which is basically
that of an individualized privatized
religion to some extent not not fully
because in different contexts is
different the United States is never a
privatized religion but is a particular
model then obviously the Catholic Church
resisted very much this model and wanted
to remain a public religion but a public
mint then tied to the state so for me
the interesting question is to analyze
the Catholic adjourn memento and how the
Catholic finally made an attempt to be
both modern and public while maintaining
its identity with the tradition rather
finally tradition so the college of
continuities in discontinuities in the
tradition about the traditions are
reformulated in the context of this
encounter with whatever we call secular
modernity and I guess this was the
experience of the Catholic
transformation linked to Vatican 2 that
open up for me the eyes well maybe
there's a thing there was a Protestant
model of transformation there is a
Catholic model of transformation I'm
sure there there it will be a Muslim
model of transformation but of course
the Catholic is one which is very much
because a hierarchical structure
organize very fast very quick and almost
without contestation the transformation
20 years radical transformation of
catholic societies in this respect in
the muslim one you have there is no
hierarchy that is no clear the final
authority so it goes in all kinds of
opposite direction so you have both
feminist and extremely
anti-feminist forms of of islam you have
pacifist and extremely violent forms of
islam and so you have the the muslim
transformation going in in multiple
directions in the same thing with
Hinduism Hinduism being transformed you
could say been for a first time being
constructed by the process of
globalization modernization in the
Korean country with Christianity and
with science and colonialism and so most
of these transformations themselves even
the Western ones were always related to
this encounter with non-western cultures
and religions and so we simply have to
open up to see how part of the crucial
component of transformation today is the
global dynamics of religions responding
to one another and and being influenced
by one another as much as they're
influenced by their own tradition so
today to understand the transformations
their relationship to their own
tradition is very important but also the
way in which they define themselves
visibly other religions or Hinduism
defines itself visible Islam and Basara
Christianity Islam defines itself is a
visualization visible and so on so you
have it in different contexts this
relationship is different and they don't
need to be necessarily oppositional
there's all sorts of borrowing that's
going all of that back and forth as well
as negotiating boundaries positively and
negatively indeed I would think that the
boundaries were never so clear-cut
probably in pre-modern times then there
is an attempt to purify boundaries to
this part of the process of
modernization but this becomes also
problematic I think there is a dynamic
tension between each religion defining
its particular
uniqueness visible other religions at
the same time presenting themselves is
the universal solution for global
humanity so we have a dynamic mode of
particularism and universalism going on
within each religious tradition and
sometimes the N vertices on the
uniqueness the particularity and the
separation therefore from the others at
other moments the moment is the
universalism and how much how Universal
in that we all share and how we can get
together and see how our universalism is
our particularistic in our particular
isms are ways of that can be somehow
connected with a universalism also and I
take it that there also partly
negotiating their their their identity
both in terms of going back to the heart
of their own tradition and also to
watching what happens that at the
boundaries and if you have simply
boundary maintenance and it's watching
the boundaries you will have a
positional definition of identities but
if the religions define themselves from
the center in part I think possibilities
emerge of exchanges and borrowing just
and so forth and there is these
definitions of course very selective
today obviously there was a time when
nobody would have used the category
judeo-christian nobody before World War
to ever use the category now everybody
talks it is a normal thing because
realize how those boundaries are not so
clear there is a common tradition we
began talking of our hammock traditions
religions right and then September 11
made the category problematic and so
some people want to completely separate
judeo-christian years but not Islam is
way so those categories are problematic
Islam is most part of the West's of the
Orion in this respect and then the more
you realize that even that our
formations of these traditions in their
golden ages of medieval Christianity
medieval Christendom medieval Judaism
all three of them are so interconnected
with the reception of Hellenism
in Aristotle and how much they they
share the same theological language in
this course let's say at this time in
Hamas we say well what they see as
almost their core from which they draw
happens to be a core which is almost
share by the three religions so it's not
only the original book and Bible and the
notion of the same yeah
that they share but also kind of the
golden age of the tradition from which
they defined themselves it's also one
which was very much in dynamic relation
to one another and we've talked now
about the self definition of religions
in interaction with one another
there's also self definition that's
going on in interaction with kind of
globalization process as kind of D
territorial ization tendencies of
globalization processes kind of
democratization tendencies and
globalization processes and others
others as well how our religions
negotiating their identity with regard
to these kinds of processes well there
there's a constant dynamic relationship
of course if you have let's say either
is what I call knowledge a regime of
secularism that defines modernity as one
in which there is no room for religion
in the public sphere then you are going
to have religion that says no but you
are asking us to basically dissolve and
disappear and to lose our identity you
to tell the judean can become a purely
private religion or that Islam can
become a private religion is basically
to deny their identity so the it's a
also dynamic relationship between
secularists conceptions of what the
global order ought to be and religions
responses to it I think we are now when
somebody even like let's say finger-like
Habermas we think is a very very kind of
typically paradigmatic european think
are very much alert to the Geist today
to the to the Geist of the spirit of the
times then calls tops of posh secular
Europe and basically because he realizes
that this moment in which the secular
define the place of religion basically
we have to rethink those issues and that
we are in a moment right now that
whatever we call global order
globalization will have to be somehow
constructed jointly through a process of
communication through all kinds of
different traditions secular and
religious so I think that we are in
dynamic both tensions but also conflicts
therefore conflict if if conflicts can
be to a certain extent
I wouldn't say contain but regulated
within bounds and obviously they can be
very productive from this what politics
is right so the question is how do we
allow for all these tensions and
conflicts to happen in their way in
which we law for this companies to
happen so they don't have to become
violent some people suggest well
likelihood within the context of
globalization processes of democratized
religions to succeed is higher than
authoritarian religions on the other
hand somebody like Peter Berger has
suggested well most of the religions
that are growing are growing precisely
by defining themselves in a position to
at least some elements of globalization
globalization processes how do you see
this dynamic of adaptation as well as of
resistance to particularly their
question is here the category of
democracy is problematic because when we
talk of democracy we talk you should
have two different things of liberty and
equality I mean this was talked a bit
talkable probably was death only through
modern social scientists that got it
right here in the sense that he realized
that the more democratization the more
religion is going to be central to polit
because he understood the monetization
primarily in terms of equalization of
conditions and the incorporation of the
masses into politics his elites may be
non-religious and he thought of the
Enlightenment but the masses even then
in Europe he thought ordinary people are
religious so when ordinary people enter
politics they bring their religion with
them so the question is for instance I
think that there is no question that
Islam is a very democratic religion in
the sense of taki billion sense of
equality of condition but it's not a
liberal village
so liberalism in democracy here are two
things we tend to see today liberalism
democracy has been the same but the 19th
century liberals were not democratic and
Democrats were non liberals were and so
part of the debate is the relationship
between democracy and liberalism and so
the question the relation between
equality and Liberty so this is
and then how these the same thing in
many of these fundamentalisms know are
very Democrat they are mass Democratic
but the question is then the protection
of minority rights this is why for for
Tocqueville the question of democracy
was the question the tyranny of the
majority and so this is the real
question how we construct structures in
which these majoritarian religious
movements can allow for the liberties of
minorities other religious and secular
minorities or by the bursa when you have
secular majorities how do you allow for
really really the possibilities of
religious minorities to participate in
the public life so and that's why the
category of separation of church and
state is not because when you have a
classical insidee you can separate
ecclesiastical institutions from a state
for the ministry verses but you cannot
separate religion and politics when you
have religious citizens to separate the
religion and party means to
disenfranchise religious people so you
cannot tell religious people you cannot
bring your religion into the public
sphere so the question is then how do
you do it in a way that you protect the
rights of minorities both secular and
religious and so this is the fundamental
question the relationship between
democracy as equality and democracy as
liberty or liberalism nothing visit
Tocqueville was the one who really
really saw this the fundamental problem
of of of modernity and if this remains
for within the context of religions also
the relation between a kind of
centralized
majoritarian consensus and the
possibility of heresy within an apostasy
those are the fundamental issues and
those are the issues I think that that
are before us especially as the world
democratizes and liberal democracy
presumably take takes takes hold in
various various settings what will
happen with various religious acting
actors in pluralistic setting in that
kind of a situation but even democracies
we tend to think of democracies once in
electoral the moment there are certain
things with democracies share in terms
of institutionalist
Jers some division of powers but then
you have different presidential is
versus parliamentary democracies the
ponies American democracy and friends
democracy those are the two kind of
paradigmatic modern democratic liberals
are very different and then you have
British is again different from the
French and American Indian democracy
eats them rgeous democratic country in
the world is very different from our
democracies democracy was not supposed
to be viable in a country like India
with hundreds of religions hundreds of
languages hundreds of ethnic groups and
yet it's very vibrant democracy with a
lot of problems but they are they are
really somehow being able to handle in
these problems in Asian Chinese
democracy when we can talk of democracy
will be very different from our
democracy even when it would not be
liberal democracy in our since I'm not
sure that we can talk of liberal
democracy in India in our sense even in
the sense that they accept morality of
legal structures for different groups so
it's they they have responded and have a
structure they are own democracy she's a
reign mention of democracy is not simply
that the British gave them a mother they
reign bent a democracy for Indian
context and I think this process going
on Indonesia has developed its own model
of democracy which is also very
interesting so so not just multiple
majorities but multiple forms of
democracy depending on cultural as well
you know we think of capitalism as one
single model but again if we think of
Chinese capitalism is very different
from the capitalism's with even American
capitalism and European we all the time
especially now as we're talking there's
a big debate how different if you are
Max Weber called Russian modern rational
capitalism then Chinese capitalism is
not mother is a state capitalism is
kinship capitalism and his gambling
combination of the three maybe for the
end of our conversation we have started
with the sense of seculars and not or
secularization this is not quite being
as persuasive as some people have
expected
to be presumption there was there a
certain resurgence of religion and there
probably there there is and the question
I suppose is why what functions do
religions play in people's lives why do
people continue to be religious in
contemporary world well we have
difficulties because we use the same
categories for different things even
religion we're not sure what rule is
whether we can't have one single thing
that we call religion that covers our
curses you know it's very hard to find
the definition of religion share by by
everybody I mean I'm I only see a family
resemblance and even that maybe too
loose nobody my own discipline the two
great founding fathers of the discipline
Durkheim and Max Weber had very
different theories of religion their
focus is very different doha means the
religion as the social we did with the
collective identity how religion self to
integrate the community how religions
serves basically to to share the same
way of thinking the same way of acting
while there is much more interested in
religion as this kind of paths of
salvation to individuals which then
entering conflicts with the rest of
society and the tensions between the war
on society so there are two different
conceptions of what religions this and
what their functions I think that both
are right and therefore we have to
integrate the two at least the aspect of
religion as a function for individuals
but then these individuals form
communities which are religious
communities which are defined in
religious community communal terms and
then the questions went to these
religious communities are in tune in
sync with also the socio-political
communities when they are in conflict
and in tension so and this is part of
the whole transnational global context
today one of the questions is in a
global context we have to develop new
identities in national identity there
are too many nations in the world to
true to the to be the wing with people
define their identity to work for the
Olympics and so on but you have this
transnational structures that were there
before the national state that have
reimbursed and this is what in this
respect Huntington is right about the
remember
of civilizations but he sees
civilizations is geopolitical
territorial units clashing with one
another but the interesting question
today is how this when I call
denominator all denominations because
part of global denominationalism going
on calling each other I'm a confusion
I'm a Hindu I'm a Muslim but this is not
any more linked to territories so that
through transnational migrations through
global processes of media and
communications in ideas then you have
the freeing of individuals from
communities community from territories
societies so you have locals national
global dynamics transnational dynamics
all at once in these both you have a
need for the definition of identities
and religion has been one of the ways of
defining collective identities but also
issues ultimately of transcendence still
remain the in man in frame is not so
much a crisis of secular modernity per
se and therefore religion is a response
to it but there is something to it there
is something that the promise of a
progressive utopian secular modernity is
the kind of secular religion has lost
the appeal it had so these all modern
ideologies that promise salvation here
on earth in a wing which all utopian
ideologies where whether socialist or or
fascist or there is a crisis of these
secular ideologies so it allows again
for new types of the definitions of
precisely the region of the self society
and the cosmos which all these
ideologies also did I mean they somehow
at least the self and society so you
have I think both a crisis of secular
modernity as a utopian ideology which is
kind of a secular religion and then you
have the redefinition of collective
identities under context of
globalization so this is one of the of
the reasons and of course this can
happen were these global identities then
class with one another
or become complementary as a form of
global denominationalism
like in the United States where you have
all kinds of religious communities which
maintain their claims to be the true
religion while accepting that my
neighbors have
from denominations someone we all can be
American so there is a saying which we
are in the pressure formation of a
global structure in which we all will
recognize that we have different
religious names different denominations
but we all have also claims to be
universal in our own way and we just
have to learn to live with one another
somehow yeah on this note of hope for
learning how to live with more than
other as we embrace overarching
interpretations of life that are very
much also a particular we can end this
very fruitful and very stimulating
conversation thank you well thank you